[Music]
michael's here michael we're very
excited to have you here i'm happy to be
here happy to be here it's been a while
since i've seen you yeah man the last
and you've never seen me i've never ever
seen billy just on the big screen
the last time we were supposed to hang
out you had invited me to now i might be
getting this wrong but was it a hawaiian
party at your house was it it wasn't it
was a tiki party yeah and that was the
last party
that we had before the pandemic at the
house and there was like
i don't know three four hundred people
there was it was insane we had a tiki
band and all that it was sort of the
party to end all party as it as it ended
up
yes it did end up yeah i seem to
remember the ticket was kind of like
maybe like a damsel in distress running
away from a volcano or something like
that and it was like hawaiian influence
yes yeah it was a whole team you have to
understand i have a whole tiki bar in
the backyard and the whole thing oh yeah
it's a whole
it's a whole thing yes it's kind of like
visiting some corner of adventureland
that you've never been to i regret it
not being in town for that party well
you should have gone in my stead yeah if
i i've been invited i would have done
yeah maybe well there will be another
one maybe next well i'd like to go we
need we need like the comeback party so
we got to do that that's true yes so
we'll do it did you didn't do the music
for the tiki thing and disney did you no
no no that was the sherman brothers
sherman brothers back in the uh 60s or
late 50s probably i mean you've done
almost everything michael your resume is
i would say up to now the most
impressive resume that we've had on the
show read it out tom well i mean i don't
even need to read it just read a little
bit i'll just tell you a few things
right bills right um
up which we'll get into up at some point
because that's that's almost transcended
the work that you've done in that film
and it has like a life of its own it
does have a life of what's
it really does i said to don when we
were talking about you coming i said
even if you've only did that
like not even all of that movie but just
at one tune from that movie i would be
happy with that yeah extraordinary
obviously
well the iconic music from last the
openings um i don't know if you remember
the opening music for lost but it went
like this
that was it
oh yeah they took pretty much right that
was the ending they took one of the drum
hits from one of the sessions and yes
boom put that on there that was lost
yeah star trek of course the recent star
trek films
um
the incredibles inside out which again
we'll get into
uh coco which i love
um did you work on super eight as well
jj's super yeah super eight yeah i'll
tell you some more things here um bells
all the mission impossible films
recently jurassic park oh jurassic world
um star trek
now ratatouille yeah uh planet of the
apes zootopia star wars rogue nation
spider-man no way home the recent the
batman film which we'll talk about as
well
and jurassic park oh jurassic world
domination which is dominion it's the
newest one which has not come out yet
all three of them but the newest one
comes out in july i think and the recent
thor love and thunder yeah
your resume is insane this is a good
guest
and we met during um
when when i was um on that tv show last
yeah now
you wrote not only the very very short
kind of clipped almost like joke-like
theme tune to the song right because
well there was two things on lost there
was the opening sort of like
thing now that
that jj did that at home on ascent on a
synth yeah and that was that and then
the boom thing was just taken from one
of our sessions we had it was a big drum
right that we used it was the end of
some queue and i think brian burke was
the one who was like oh that that should
be the thing we use for the amazing yeah
so that was that and uh that show was
one of my favorite shows i ever worked
on yeah and just incredible we were
doing a music quiz billy and i a few
months ago now and we were scrolling
through a few things and billy's saying
do you know this do you know that and
billy played me a song from something
and i went oh wait wait i know this i
know this it's a sad moment in a tv show
uh
some one of the characters dying i think
billy's like yeah yeah i went now i
can't think it was when charlie dies in
lost he was like you probably should
know that you should probably
you should yeah it's like 15 years if
you don't know that charlie died in last
it's 15. it's fine you you've you're the
people that they you know they so what
they weave yeah yeah it's it's it's so
when they
reap reap it's been a long enough time
and you and i share a good friend jj and
what i've noticed with jj over the years
i mean this is true of all all friends
if if you really want to have a fun
conversation with them ask them to talk
about something that they're passionate
about and this would be music jj is
obsessed with music yes he is obsessed
with me actually i'll tell you the first
time i met jj uh so you have to
understand i was working in video games
at that time i was scoring video games i
did a game called um i did the lost
world jurassic park this video game a
playstation game and then i did a
follow-up medal of honor
so those games were out in the world i
was trying to get a job working in
television scoring tv shows right
because i i just wanted to kind of build
and move and do more things but no one
would hire me nobody everyone kept
saying and i did a million interviews
but they would all say no you know what
video games aren't like tv you can't
possibly know how to do this and even
though those projects
were both like helmed by
uh steven spielberg was producing them
because he was they were his movies and
and he was really into them and uh that
didn't matter so i was sitting there one
of these days i was just kind of
depressed because i couldn't get
anywhere couldn't get anything i got
this email
from this guy named jj and i was like
who is this and he's like hey my name is
jj abrams um i uh just i wrote
armageddon and regarding henry i'm about
to do a new tv show for abc and i was
wondering if you'd want to come in and
talk about doing the music for it i love
the music you do on the games
so i was like what i thought somebody
was joking with me i thought it was like
you know someone's screwing and i but i
called the number he answered the phone
and he's like hey do you want to come in
this week so i went over and went over
to disney
i got in i walk into his office and we
start talking we start talking about
synths and different things and he went
you know off the charts he loves that
stuff so he's like well come here so he
went into this other room where he had
all his keyboards set up and we started
messing around with that yes pull this
thing out put that in there start
talking about all that so in the middle
of talking about that
this woman comes in for him to look at
and make sure that the hair was good and
the costume was fitting and everything
because they were going to start
shooting i think in a day or two and
that was jennifer garner and i at the
time i had no idea who jennifer garner
was and i was like and then and then um
bradley came in as well a couple minutes
later he would come he came in and he
and all these people who are now just
like you know huge amounts of this this
day that i met jj was like also meeting
all these other people in the cast and i
ended up on the show and then that's
kind of how that wow all went crazy yeah
i remember saying to jj and and because
i have a couple of synths that i mess
about with at home in fact jj set me up
with the whole set up with a with a moog
he was like do you have a moog i said no
he said okay i'm sending you some stuff
sent me a moo sent me some other little
contraptions that you can attach to your
move to make it sound different and all
this kind of stuff and then we were
talking one day because i've seen that
suite of his that's just wires you
unplug one thing it makes a different
sound and then you plug it back in again
and i said to jay does it not
slightly frustrate you that maybe you
find a found a sound and then if you
unplug one wire that sound might
disappear forever and jj said no that's
the thing i like the most about this
process is maybe you're creating a sound
via the synth that has never been heard
before and may never get heard again
that's right you just have to have the
moment yeah which is a beautiful kind of
lesson in art it's a great thing but i
mean for the guys that used to do that
all the time you know they'd have sheets
and tracks and they would write down
every number this goes to that this goes
to that it was like you know puzzle
pieces it was it's insane but that stuff
is fun
so what is your musical background then
my musical background is piano lessons
right as a group
just but but not like intense piano
lessons like like the guy down the
street mr coletti taught me piano since
five years old sort of thing i would say
from like six to maybe
12 or 13 and then maybe i went back for
a little bit when i actually was
interested in it because at that time i
was just like oh he had to go take me on
a lesson
i hated practicing hated all that and
then there came a time when i started
getting more interested in music and i
was like you know i'm gonna go back to
mr coletti and take some lessons with
him now i'm much older yeah went back
down there and i started asking him
the thing i wanted to know was like i
understood i could pick out a melody on
the piano and that was fine like i could
play star wars whatever yeah uh
but what i didn't understand was what
was happening underneath all of that and
that that and he goes oh you mean like
chord progressions i'm like i don't know
maybe and he goes it's like this you
start on a c you go to an f you go to
that and i started doing that i was like
oh my that like blew my mind it blew my
mind because you could change the
character of anything by the chords you
put underneath it okay so any melody
could become either say happy or
melancholy or or just terrifying or
whatever it is depending on what you do
what the support you give it so that to
me was fascinating now
that was just more of like me very
interested in music i was never
on a path to become a film composer yeah
never thought that's what i'd be doing i
thought i'd be
it depends on when you asked me if you
asked me when i was a kid i would have
been building models and blowing them up
for movies you know like
in a special effects department
somewhere that's what i loved so i was
thinking i would work in special effects
and then and i made movies
all my life growing up that's all i did
was make movies right so i have tons of
movies so i just wanted to make movies
music i kind of fell into and it just
sort of like took over everything and uh
and before you know it like 20 years go
by and you know all these movies and all
this stuff and you're like wow that is
not at all
at all what i thought i'd be doing right
you know no idea because i didn't go to
conservatory i didn't do all that
i ended up studying so much on my own
once i really got more serious about it
and kind of interested it was really a
hobby and i would write music on
weekends and that night and um and i
read every book i could i took some
classes at juilliard didn't i didn't
quite fit in there um any time you tried
to write a melody there they would smack
your hand like the nuns would smack you
know it was just like no it's not about
this it's about exploration and atonal
and figuring out new textures and sounds
i was like i just want to write a melody
i just want to you know so i didn't it
didn't go that great for me over there i
appreciate the time there but it was
like not for me when i
moved out to la
you know my main job at that time was
working
in publicity and i was an assistant in
the publicity offices of disney right so
i was on the disney lot working there
and then i'd go to school at ucla at
night and learn orchestration and
arranging and all of that stuff uh
again at that point i started thinking
well maybe this is something i could do
i don't know um and then the video again
it's such a long crazy thing so
publicity then i got a job producing
video games for disney as a producer and
then eventually they started asking me
to write music for those video games so
it was like maui mallard it was
gargoyles it was pocahontas a little bit
of that or you know uh some stuff online
king it was like it was crazy so i was
setting up a small studio in a space
like this
um and i started writing music for them
and then did the same thing over at
dreamworks i was producing video games
but also writing music for them and
eventually i was like can i just write
the music do i have to
produce the video games and they were
like i said i would love to quit and
just work at home and do this and they
were like great so that's what i did in
lost worlds when i did medal of honor
and then there's like five medal of
honors and i also did call of duty and
all these other
video games that are you know um
sort of these crazy big games of their
time but at that time i was just
thinking in the same way i was thinking
how am i going to get from video games
to tv once i got into television i was
like how am i going to get into
movies i want to do movies i want to
score movies now
that was the same thing no one would
hire me because
you know television's very different
from you know uh you couldn't possibly
understand what it's like to score a
film you do television and that's a very
different thing and i was like
okay but uh on alias and on lost as you
know we did full orchestra
every week
boom boom boom for every episode and it
was a grind but it was
great it was so great to work with the
musicians who are the greatest in the
world you know every week uh so that was
such a great training ground for me and
the thing that sort of changed it all
was brad bird
when disney was or pixar was doing the
incredibles
they had hired john barry at first you
know and he was supposed to be on that
film
and for whatever reason that didn't work
out so they had spent all their money
they were looking for a new composer but
they had no money and so
since uh
lost an alias mainly alias is a disney
property
the people at disney said oh we're
working with this young guy who's been
doing this show
maybe that'll work and so they sent all
the stuff up to brad i also had another
friend independently
who gave stuff to the editor uh for him
to play because uh he would put it into
the cut and then brown be like well what
is this music what is this and they were
like oh this is one of teddy's friends
my friend teddy newton
um and he's like well let's meet him so
i went up met brad and then that that
sort of sealed the deal for movies so so
but that was a movie that i thought
every inch along the way i was going to
get fired because i was like i had no
right
to be sitting up there doing a pixar
movie after people like you know randy
newman and thomas newman had been
scoring their movies yeah you know
you're just like
so i never ever thought that would have
i would have survived that process
but i did thankfully and uh and it was a
blast and i became best friends with
brad bird who's
just one of the greatest you should talk
to brad yeah he should get us a job
shouldn't he yeah
[Laughter]
using the internet without expressvpn
that's like walking your dog in public
without a leash now
some of the time that might be okay but
there might come a day when your dog
will run away or even worse get
dog-mapped imagine it terrible anyway
it's better to be careful
especially when it's as simple as using
express vpn every time you connect to an
unencrypted network whether it's a cafe
hotels airports wherever
your online data is not secure any
hacker on the same network can gain
access and steal all your personal data
but expressvpn creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that they can't steal it
it would take a hacker with a super
computer over a billion years to get
past express vpn's encryption that's a
long time
and
expressvpn works in all your devices
your phone your laptop your tablet even
your smart tv
and it's super easy to use it's an app
and you click one button and you're
protected when i'm in a hotel
airport wherever
i never use the internet without
expressvpn
especially when i'm doing something on
the banks or credit cards
keep it secure
and you can get an extra three months of
expressvpn free at expressvpn.com
onion that's expressvpn.com
onion expressvpn.com
slash
onion
now a word from our sponsor betterhelp
guys it's been a rough couple of years i
think a lot of people have experienced
burnout i know i have to and burnout
isn't always associated with being busy
too much at work or having a crazy life
sometimes it can just be due to the fact
that there's a lot going on right now
the news is a stressful thing to watch
and we could all take a little bit of
time just to kind of relax maybe have
our life feel a little bit less
overwhelming and just enjoy ourselves a
little bit better help online therapy
wants to remind you to prioritize
yourself
talking with someone can help you figure
out what's causing stress in your life
for me it always really helps to just
have someone to talk to and that's the
whole deal with better help you can
access these people online super easy
and they can provide some therapy to get
you through those tougher times
in our day better help is customize
online therapy that offers video phone
and even live chat sessions with your
therapist so you'd have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours our listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
but isn't that the the weird thing isn't
it when you when you take that step to
whether you call it a step up but a step
to somewhere else
you feel like i'm not worthy we've been
talking about this for the last few
weeks this imposter syndrome that a lot
of people have yes and you forget that
somebody has to do it somebody else
well what you eventually realize
and it takes some time and it takes some
trust as you realize nobody knows
anything right nobody knows anything
right everyone is just doing their best
to guess you know what i mean that
moment that moment i'll make this yes
like when you get as you're talking
about melodies your melodies are just
incredible by the way
but
like if you can pick out that melody
yeah then everything else will work out
yes exactly as you're saying about
putting the different chords down you
went to ucla to learn orchestration i
mean that's amazing that you did that
yeah and eve there must have been
something in the back of your mind that
you're like no exactly this is sort of
going somewhere i've always like gone
after things but with the thought in my
mind that it's probably never gonna work
out you know what i mean like you know
the if it the less you expect that the
happier you can stay yeah you know but i
think that realization that once you
realize that everyone at every point in
whatever they're doing is just trying to
figure it out just like you
there's a freedom in that you know and
then you become comfortable failing i'm
okay
look failure is the thing you shoot for
because it means you're trying for
something right it means you're trying
for something so
uh if you fail the worst that can happen
is you learn something right you learn
from it um but every you guys too i have
all of us like whatever
we're no better than almost you know
than anybody else around like everyone
you're just been given the opportunity
and you delivered on it and you continue
to get to do that so
yeah we fail we fail all the time you
especially yeah i feel most days
you're absolutely right and i'm trying
i'm trying to teach that to my son just
now who's very into music just now he's
playing everything
and i'm just like don't be afraid to
like
you know sing awfully or or play the
wrong thing and just try that chord just
because someone said that chord doesn't
fit there might you try it yeah there
are other wrong chords right there's no
rules to anything that's so so great
about art there's no rules
you know and when everyone likes to
impose these rules or they have these
self-imposed rules but it's all a bs and
you just go for what makes you feel
happy and what feels right to you yeah
that's all you can do yeah you know the
second you try to do what you think
someone else would do you're dead in the
water for sure you know let me can we
just ask you a little bit about pixar
because correct me if i'm wrong but it
it's always felt like to me
that music is especially important for
pixar yeah they almost have
a a very established ethos over at pixar
you know obviously the we know the thing
about tugging on the heart strings in
terms of the script and also the
complement of the music but
would it be fair to say that pixar take
their music a little bit more seriously
than than other places yes they do they
do and that's why i love that place i
think they take everything more
seriously right than other places you
know the thing about pixar is that i
love the most is that those characters
are treated as if they are real people
you know every character you work with
is treated as if it was a real person in
your world you know when i when i work
on everyone's always says oh
cartoons it must be that must be easier
than scoring like a live action you're
like
it's the exact same thing because
whether i'm scoring a scene where you're
getting strung up and hung and lost you
know like in a real situation or if i'm
dealing with remy who is the rat who is
just trying to figure his life out like
they're both characters and they're both
real and they both deserve to be treated
as real characters so much animation
treats them as jokes yeah treats them as
just a like a puppet or something you
know and a silly a two-dimensional silly
sort of thing whereas
uh pixar has a very different approach
to it and it's it happens to fit in
exactly how i feel about scoring which
is
whatever's on that screen treat it as if
it's real and and try to empathize with
how would you feel if you were that
person or that rat or that whatever you
know fish doesn't matter uh because
ultimately they're they're they're
telling human stories but through these
these crazy characters whether it is the
fish or the rat or whatever um
and it's just treating them like humans
and i think that that respect that they
have
um
is is is part of what you're talking
about that respect for the characters
yeah is is everything and and just just
to kind of break down a little bit the
practicalities of what you do let's say
for the example of pixar do you get
delivered of a cut of the movie and they
say hey michael we need a minute and a
half here we need three minutes here we
need the closing song here like how does
that work for you basically
i'll go up there and i'll sit and we'll
watch it together right you know and
we'll watch the whole thing and then
what we'll do is kind of go through it
again but we'll stop and start and we'll
discuss i think music should start here
and you know and they may say we want
music here and i may say i don't think
you should have music there or it could
be the opposite they i would say i don't
think you need it they say so it's a
discussion throughout the whole thing
because we're trying to figure out
what's the art because music
brad i remember when brad first hired me
for the incredibles it was like this
arduous long process and i did demos and
all of this crazy stuff and uh but when
they finally hired me he called me up
and he was like
okay
giakino you got the job
he goes i just and i was like that's
amazing thank you so much this is like
crazy and he was like hold on hold on
he goes i just have to tell you
something i want you to know
that your music could ruin my movie
right and i was just like all this joy
just went to like oh my god what i get
myself into here what's going on and he
was like just he goes bear with me
because what i mean is
if your music isn't following the same
story that i'm telling at every step of
the way if we are not holding hands the
entire time the audience is going to
start thinking things that we don't want
them to think they're going to start
feeling things we don't want them to
feel and they'll get distracted and then
they'll get they won't pay attention to
the story so you and i have to always
discuss and figure out and just stay
together and make sure we're telling the
story the way it needs to be told
because music can completely ruin a
movie and i've seen it just i'm
hypersensitive to it so almost
everything i watch is is so easily just
like ruined by one wrong thing for me
because i'm like
it takes you out of the moment it's a
subconscious thing too even if you don't
know about music or how this all works
when you're watching something and
something doesn't feel right it could be
any number of things but in large large
amount of the times it's because it's
the wrong music playing under a
particular scene it's either pushing too
hard
or it's or it's not pushing hard enough
or it's big when it should be soft or
soft when it should be big and those are
all these crazy you can't just write a
piece of music and throw it behind
something
and expect it to work it's got to evolve
and ebb and flow in the same way that
the the writer has taken the time to do
with the script and the story or the
storyboard artists
who are also a huge part of the story uh
process up at pixar i've seen little
clips of the original star wars uh film
a new hope without music yeah and it's
terrible it's crazy right it's just
terrible there's no drive there's no
drama it feels much more kind of
cheap and homemade and then williams
brings in this
amazing dramatic space opera he's a
great storyteller too john was is one of
the best sort of like
uh he can he can zero in on those
emotions so well better than anybody and
uh and that's really i mean i learned so
much of that just by
watching the movies he scored
by listening to his music and seeing
what i used to do is i would take my
tape recorder to the movie theaters so i
would go see raiders of the lost ark or
empire strikes back whatever it was and
i would record the whole movie
and i would at night uh
listen to it under my pillow on the tape
recorder and i would just every night
that's what i would do and i would
listen to the movie
and i
looking back i'm real i i realized that
i learned so much doing that just by
understanding how the music works with
the story like you don't have the
visuals to distract you you can
concentrate just on how the music and it
wasn't anything i was doing at the time
list you know figuring it out it was
just i look back in all those time
listening to how music works with words
how it works with sound and all of that
it was such a
an enlightening experience i i think
that it it helped me immensely just by
you know pirating all those movies yeah
yeah so in the process then are you
always brought in
when it's a finished visual no it's
always different like a lot of the pixar
stuff when i start on it all a lot of it
could be storyboards still
you know yeah like i i just finished
light year so lightyear's going to be
coming out soon
um and when i started working on that
there was a lot it was a mix of boards
of what they call previz which is sort
of just you know some of the action on
uh
rendered out in 3d but not lit and not
no details or any of that characters
walking around their arms straight out
yeah it's very strange looking stuff um
but a lot of times i'll start on in that
uh when it looks like that
um so but i do like to at least see a
version of the movie before i
start writing for it because i find that
if i start writing for something
in most cases batman was different but
in most cases i will wait till i see it
before i write something right okay you
know because when you read a script
you tend to envision
your version of that movie yeah right
when you're reading something and then
you get on set or you you you see the
final thing that they made and you're
like that's nothing like that i
envisioned yeah and then you're and i've
wrote all this music yes and now nothing
works yes so i don't i don't do that
because that's just double work
um so i usually wait to see something
and see what the tone is and what
they're going for and trying to align
with that
um so batman was different so the batman
which i've just watched you saw a couple
of days ago i didn't know i was late to
it and it's brilliant i loved it thanks
it's really and the music's incredible
thank you so
why was that different um that was
different because matt reeves uh gave me
the script to read he was like read it
cause i want it and it wasn't read it
because here's what we're making it was
read it tell me what you think if
there's anything you know give me notes
um so i was like okay so i read it and i
loved it and it was amazing and it felt
like
i was like how are you going to make
this movie it's so sprawling and epic
and and not in an action way but in a
character way like this crazy like he
matt is one of my favorite directors to
work with matt is incredible and he's
very intense and he goes deep as he can
on the storytelling
but when i read that script i got such a
vibe for what he was doing and after
talking about it with him that i i went
ahead and wrote um that theme for that
you know that's that's in the movie and
that was and that's just from reading it
just from reading it yeah
and i was just sitting after i read it i
remember going to the piano in the
living room and just messing around and
coming up at that thing and just being
like oh yeah this feels like batman like
i remember thinking in my head like
if i were batman if i'm wearing that
suit and i'm like stalking what would
that feel like like what what kind of
tension would that be in my head and
what does that emotion
sound like you know musically and that's
where just came up with that
that motif for him and
uh we that was
written and we recorded a version of it
like almost two years before the movie
was finished
hiring right now is hard no one is more
committed to helping businesses than
indeed that's why they're giving away 50
million dollars in indeed sponsored job
credits to help businesses like yours
hire great people fast
indeed is the hiring platform where you
can attract interview and hire all in
one place
instead of spending hours on multiple
job sites searching for candidates with
the right skills
indeed's a powerful hiring partner that
can help you do it all
with instant match over 80 percent of
employers get quality candidates whose
resumes on indeed match their job
description the moment they sponsor a
job according to indeed data us
indeed saves you headaches you can
interview virtually with no downloads
plugins or purchases and you can do it
all in one place with indeed
even better indeed the only job site
where you only pay for applications that
meet your must-have requirements
sign up for indeed now and get 75
dollars credit towards your first
sponsored job plus earn up to 500
extra and sponsor job credits with
indeed's virtual interviews
visit indeed.com slash onion to learn
more claim your credits at indeed.com
slash onion
indeed dot com slash onion terms and
conditions apply need to hire
you need indeed
now we're all trying to eat better we're
all trying to get healthier and that's a
good thing we we should
but
that doesn't mean we've got to have a
boring breakfast
no
we can still eat fun stuff and it can be
healthy
like magic spoon cereal it's really
great stuff
if you like cereal like i do
like cold milk on your cereal in the
morning oh that's lovely
but with magic spoon
you don't get all the rubbish and all
the sugar it's actually very very good
so if you're trying to cut down on sugar
and carbs and unhealthy food this is the
stuff for you i'll give you some facts
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving the
honey nut flavor is only get one gram of
sugar
only 140 calories a serving is keto
friendly it's gluten free it's grain
free soy free and it's low carb
build your own box there are nine
available flavors and they're all
fantastic
you've got cocoa fruity
frosted i love the frosted peanut butter
cookies and cream maple waffle blueberry
muffins cinnamon roll and honey nut
and even more exciting magic spoon has
just brought back their cereal bars they
were so popular they brought them back
permanently it's the perfect
convenient on-the-go companion for your
cereal so go to
magicspoon.com to grab your custom
bundle of cereal and be sure to use our
promo code onion at checkout you'll save
five dollars off your order and magic
spin is so confident and their product
is backed with a hundred percent
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund your
money no questions asked remember get
your next delicious bowl of guilt-free
cereal at magicspoon.com
onion and use the code onion to save
five dollars off
there was also a time when i worked with
the wachowskis
who who are both amazing and they said
um
we would like you to write the score for
the movie before we shoot it and this
was for jupiter ascending
and and i was like oh that's interesting
they're like you know because when
you're making a movie you use and you're
editing it together
they use what they call temp music which
basically is just any music from
anywhere you got just rip it off a cd
and it could be from
any movie that could movie from music
from star wars into whatever um
so they they're like we hate using tent
music because it's like putting on
somebody others somebody else's clothes
it doesn't really ever fit right and you
have to work your butt off to try and
get it to look good or feel good or
sound good and they're like so we
thought if you could write the score
before we shoot the movie
then we could just edit to that and i
was like okay
so i went ahead and i recorded like i
don't know 80 or 90 minutes of music
i you know they said what would you need
to do that i said could you give me
um note cards which describe each
character and note cards which describe
the main scenes that are going to be the
big the big set pieces
and the overall story they sent me all
of the artwork all the production
artwork as they were designing things i
had this whole book of stuff that i
could look through if i wanted
inspiration i could look through all of
this it was basically like writing an
opera you know to something and
it was so fun and freeing just to go
ahead and write whatever you wanted and
we went over to london recorded it at
abbey road and we had this
it was just this incredible experience
of like okay
now we're gonna find out how much of
this actually works in the movie that
they that they shoot
so uh i think in the end 75 of it worked
and 25 of it we went back and and scored
uh traditionally like i get the picture
and i would score it to picture but 75
of it was
from the stuff that we recorded from
that initial run which was crazy that's
pretty amazing and the wachowskis take
the music in their films very seriously
yes yes
yes i love the um
the
soundtrack to cloud atlas
cloud atlas was kind of
a little bit uh it's a crazy movie
criticized by you know i thought i
thought it was lovely i love it too so
ambitious and of course a little flawed
like most films are but that reach is so
ambitious and they're the best the music
in that was fantastic yeah
um also just to touch on the batman for
a second
i don't mat i don't know matt reeves but
i read a lot of interviews with him
during his process
and he had mentioned that he listened to
something in the way by nirvana a lot
which has that obviously features in the
movie quite a lot but has that
relatively iconic bass line
this is the crazy thing so that is also
part of your
music right and i
so when i read the script i had no idea
that that song was going to be used and
i am embarrassed to say i did not know
that song uh i wasn't a big nirvana fan
so i wasn't sure about that and then
when we started when i first saw the cut
of the movie
i was realizing wait these actually
worked together really well really well
they weren't sliding they weren't
different keys but we had to once we put
it in the right key it was like oh they
actually work well together yeah because
batman has that bum
bum bum bum bum so it's a different
rhythm but it it's the same it fits and
complementary yes they complement each
other so that was like a complete lucky
strike right you know completely lucky
on that one have you been in this
situation i mean that's obviously not
exactly what i was
the the thing that i'm going to mention
now is that have you been in a situation
with a filmmaker where they've said hey
michael we really want you to score
our film but here's the tonality song
that we want it to
be around it does it doesn't work like
that usually those things are happening
separately right uh they probably should
happen together it'd be a lot more
cohesive
but
a lot of times the songs that they pick
for movies aren't picked until
somewhere deep into editing or sometimes
or sometimes they might have one that
they want through the whole thing but
that changes all the times
because sometimes the song that they
have their their heart set on is because
is way too expensive to get right or you
know they're not available or whatever
or they come up with a better idea so
it's always changing right so in the
scoring side of things i'm usually sort
of
apart from all of that i'm so surprised
that they got something in the way by
nirvana because you would assume that's
relatively expensive right but yeah
yeah but the way that it works it works
beautifully you know because i don't
think they've yet achieved although they
did in this particular batman the idea
of that slight
negative emo heavy
vibe he's an orphan but he's a
billionaire he gets looked at in the
streets he's kind of an unwanted kind of
celebrity of sorts he's got a lot of
self-loathing as we know with kurt
cobain and a lot of the music that he
had written because of his mental health
there is issues with fame there is
issues with feeling worthless and stuff
like that and that
it's it's one of the i said to billy
before he watched the film i said i'll
try not to spoil it for you but i said
it has one of the greatest needle drops
in recent memory of the movie just that
start of that nirvana bass line is so
good it's great and the pushing of the
little boy because i've
seen what's happened at the start of the
film yep and you see bruce watching him
thinking
i watch my parents yeah dying i'm that
kid i'm that kid yeah yeah there's a
there's a the thing i love about matt is
he's not afraid of bringing in
sadness to something it's
you know to really go after real
emotions for something yeah even if you
watch the plan of the apes movies that
we've done together like there's they
are littered with sadness the whole
thing i ca and it's something i
love to tap into as well for things
because i feel like there's such a
connection
to people through sadness through
understanding through all of that so i
think musically i tend to do that
well i mean if you just watch lawsuit
half of that is just all sad
and a lot of the pixar stuff i mean the
profundity of things like up and inside
out inside out i mean coco as well but i
mean inside out i think is one of the
most
sophisticated tellings of
emotions to young people you know the
fact that that great messaging inside
out that like sometimes sadness can
teach us really valuable things about
our life
it's really it's not something to push
away right you know or be scared of
because if you're scared of feeling sad
and that's going to happen at some point
in your life how do you manage it when
it actually shows up i mean as a parent
i think the thing the worst thing you
can say to your kid is don't be sad
don't be sad it's like no
embrace that sadness and let's talk
about why you feel that way exactly you
know but but everyone's knee-jerk
reaction in the world is to
don't be sad or a kid who falls down and
hurts his knees crying and you tell the
kid oh you're fine you're fine it's like
don't cry don't cry i had this moment
yesterday yeah
no i took my dog to the park your dog
cried my dog get bit by a huge dog oh my
gosh
basically my dog's tennis 12 pounds and
this dog had my dog in his mouth so i
went over and i was freaking out you
know and anyway the dog was fine
and then both dogs both dogs are fine
then i've got the dog then
who's normally left in the house when
i'm out doing stuff i took him in the
car everywhere
and and
and i picked up my son at one point my
wife was already in the car
and
jack said to me why is why is bobbing i
was telling him and i said you know i
i don't like my family being sad and
then i immediately thought of that movie
and i said but don't feel like you can't
be sad yeah yeah i said you can be sad
yeah i'm just gonna like
you know do everything i can to help you
out whatever it is it's made me sad make
sure you tell me and i actually had that
moment in the car because of that movie
but did you notice that was was bobby a
little traumatized for the rest of the
day was he all right i was just sure
maybe because you were traumatized yeah
he had a big exercise day this isn't
about music here but i love the bomb
it's okay but maybe you had to embrace
your sadness
i was very he had a big exercise day
before he ended up in this dog's mouth
yeah
so i don't know if he was just exhausted
but at one point he was on my knees and
he just became a dead weight
i thought he was dead oh no so i put my
hand on his little heart but i was still
going and i said bobby and he just sat
up straight away but i thought it it
folded into my yeah yeah what a
beautiful place to die that's where i'm
going to die but i know you're on your
lap
i'm good i'm going to be the one i'm
going to be the one holding your hand
you'll be struggling
checking your heartbeat just wait wait
wait i gotta understand i got right what
did the other dogs own or how did they
react
right
he's hungry
i hadn't been to this um i hadn't been
to this dog park for a while and now
it's sort of been overrun by dog walkers
oh dog walker and there's another dog
walker who goes there who i love she's a
wonderful lady and looks after
um i said that as if she's a hundred
years old she's you know she's just a
woman kind of thing
but um
she looks after bobby sometimes when
we're out of town and she said that this
dog walker sometimes isn't keeping a
good eye on these dogs and uh this dog
was becoming more aggressive over the
weeks she'd eaten a couple of chickens a
rabbit a gerbil
just give you a piece of advice what
happens again
if that big dog yeah grabs hold of bobby
yeah in his mouth what you need to do
okay is lick both your fingers and shove
them up in the big dogs teeters yeah
because he can't
have an animal in its mouth while
fingers are going up his bottom yeah
it's good
it's going to release the animal you
promise me that you'll do that
on my handle my might break your fingers
off or
might be your best friend we might fall
in love exactly you never know
to get back to music please no um
this could be different every in every
everything that you do
but
what is the process normally for you
of the actual
melody chords orchestration
do you do all of that or do you get a
melody and a chord structure and you say
okay that's good let's send that to them
i'll do the rough orchestrations of all
of it like i'll do these right you know
uh that because what you have to do also
is you do what they call mock-ups you
know so i can do a mock-up on the
computer of what it's going to sound
like uh and that way you can show the
director what what it's gonna be like
against picture and all of that so to do
that you know you're using strings
patches and all the kinds of things like
that horns yeah horns woodwinds piano
harp whatever it is so i have a whole
setup that has all of that stuff at the
ready all you have to do is choose which
one and then you can play the piano and
that's the sound you get and if you
don't mind me asking
how do you how do you write harmony
and
orchestration for different and do you
do that the reason i'm asking is i asked
howard shore once and he's he's he says
look i'm old school i sit with a piece
of paper yeah and that and that to me
would be like
somebody saying build
a spaceship and go to the moon yes it is
a bit like that i enjoy music but i have
to work it out right from my gut i can't
sit and say okay this is yeah old do you
do i used to do a lot more of that uh
but now it's all you know you can the
computer has basically replaced paper
you know so you can you they have you
know notation programs so we do it on on
a program called sibelius is where all
the final sort of orchestration is done
right i do all my writing in a program
called digital performer and that's
where it has all those tracks so that
way when i hand that off to the
orchestrator
he's already knows okay uh the strings
are doing this the woodwinds are doing
this uh brass is doing this
i've already done it and it's up to them
to then tie it all together finesse it
they might you know they have to also
it's a lot of detail work which is
incredible all of the articulation so
what i'll do is i'll write on top i'll
give notes on top okay this is legato
these strings are playing this way that
way they're crescendo into this this is
loud this is this is you know piano this
is forte all of those things i write all
of that in there so they have a perfect
guide for what to do um and i happen to
work with one of the greatest
orchestrators on the planet his name is
jeff cricka and he is like just he's
magic this guy is magic he can do
anything and there are times if you're
really rushed i could say jeff i just
wrote the bare bones to this um i need
you to fill this out and
and and here's exactly what i want and
he can do it in two seconds and jeff's
an amazing composer in his own right too
like he can do that as well but it is a
a team effort without a doubt you know
uh getting everything down i can do all
of that and
also the other nice thing about having
it that way is when the director comes
in and checks it out if there's
something that
they're not feeling right about we can
explore it i can go okay let's change it
and i'll change this i'll say okay well
instead maybe what you're feeling is
that this instrument is giving too much
of something and let's change it into
something like this
right in front of them and then they can
go yes that works
as opposed to waiting like i like to do
all of that ahead of time as opposed to
doing it on the stage
because then it's a mess you know and
then you're okay and you can do it and i
can change things very easily on the
stage as well just a much longer process
yeah it's longer and you're like okay
you guys play this you don't play this
play this instead of that you're like
passing out new parts and all that stuff
so you're kinda back to that piano
lesson where
you've got the melody yes well i'm
changing what's going on underneath
exactly yes exactly and that will give
you whatever feeling that you're wanting
or a director's one yes exactly yep
before
billy's son who's 16 now 16 was born
really and i think ali was was your
girlfriend at this point not even your
fiance not even your wife certainly
billy and i went to see up
at a cinema in westwood have you ever
seen me cry that much watching the movie
honestly so it was billy
it was billy in the middle
his wife to his right me on the left
and i don't generally cry this much in
the movie i was doing that like catching
my breath cry like yeah
trying to like catch my breath and billy
looked over me a few times just coming
you know and i was like oh boy i'm okay
but so nowhere after i mean i was
devastated watching that film yeah and a
huge part of that
was the song
and that particular song that you wrote
which we touched upon at the start of
the interview has taken on this life
excuse me of its own i follow a lot of
uh positivity kind of uh social media
sites
there's a guy called tanks good news
that is just good news that you find
around the world he puts up or there'll
be clips of little kids doing something
great or soldiers coming back from you
know service and all this kind of stuff
i would say
at least 60 to 70 percent of the time
it's that oh really sonic song from up
so you should probably be getting money
for this michael but
if it's all right with you and you've
probably been asked this question so
many times but
when you sat down to create that
beautiful simple
piano song you obviously knew the story
you knew what was going on how did you
how did you kind of decide on this this
melody well that one
if i recall correctly happened in the
shower and not at the piano
uh
that was what i had seen the movie and
i've been thinking about it and pete
docter and i had a discussion and pete
was like it'd be great if it felt like
it was like a music box sort of a melody
that you could hear and yes and you
remember and it's just sort of like and
we also knew that we
wanted some sort of waltz that felt like
a couple's dance
um but i remember being in the shower
and that melody
was in my head
and i remember thinking like oh i should
go write this down
and then i said to myself well
i'm not going to write it down if i
remember this tomorrow
then maybe that's a good sign so i just
let it go
i let it go and then the next day i was
like all right i was back up at the
office let me see if i can remember this
thing and i did and i thought okay
that's a good sign if i remembered that
there then then that's that's maybe
that's i'm on to something there was a
an another version of that melody that
happened first or maybe it was born out
of this because you don't always just
nail it right away and you're just sort
of like but but the bones were there and
out of that came that theme and i
remember uh playing it for pete and he
was like yep that that that that's it
you know and when we recorded
that on we recorded that on the warner
brothers the sound stage the the
eastwood scoring stage and um where they
recorded tons of warner brothers
cartoons and all this stuff which is
great it's got a great history to it but
i remember when we recorded it so for
the first time we're doing that scenes
one of the first scenes we did
um
when the when the scene was over
everyone was just crying like everybody
like the musicians were crying the
director the producer all of us were in
the booth crying everyone is just sort
of like
okay let's do it again now you have to
do it again it's just the opening the
the the whole montage
yeah yeah that was one of the first
things that we recorded because we
wanted to make sure that that it was
working and all of that and that
everything was doing what it needed to
do
but even then you know because not you
think about these guys that have been
working on this film you know they had
been working on this from probably five
years yeah by that point you know uh at
least so so so when you hear something
that connects like that you're not only
thinking about what's happening in that
movie you're thinking about what you
went through you know in the last five
years of your life and how hard these
things are to make and everything you do
to kind of to get to this point so it
all these emotions come up with music
it's such a weird thing it can trigger
you in so many different ways yeah you
know
and like you had said that melody is
everything that you guys tried to
achieve i i love the idea that you
mention a music box thing in terms of it
it builds it starts off just a little
slow in its timing and then it kind of
builds up to this
waltz thing but this
this idea almost that there's something
not quite fully realized about it at
first and then the melody kicks in and
in the same way that the the major
characters lives kind of start a little
they're not quite there yet they're kind
of a couple they're figuring stuff out
and then oh it builds they get married
and they have this life and
my god yeah it's what an incredible and
so you want an oscar for the score of up
yes
more than anything else do you think it
was probably driven by that particular
melody yeah probably yeah i think so i
mean that that i think it was really
that scene that married life scene yeah
because the thing about that scene is
you watch it and you're like
it it it's everything in your life it's
it's everything you will go through in
your life
and some of those things you may have
gone through already some of those
things are things you're going to go
through you know and and it's just that
whole sort of um
that incredible tapestry that is that is
sort of suggested by that step by those
scenes is
you know we can all relate to that yeah
we can all relate to that my son has a
as well in his class he was supposed to
do some piece of movie-making this year
and his first choice although it became
too much for him was to try and do a
live version of that montage really yeah
yeah that was that's ambitious when
someone said what you're going to do
that's what he said wow so i mean it's
touched so many people
every level of age and as you say
because you're at one level yeah you
know he might have been falling in love
with someone at that point and just
related to that exactly you know and
you're getting old and probably won't
make up i'm not just saying yeah no
now oscar night because billy and i
we're waiting for our oscars they're in
the mail they said right i think so yeah
they're coming in a couple weeks
but oscar night yeah
is everyone talks about this idea of you
know as soon as you hear your name the
next kind of five minutes of your life
is a little bit of a blur it's a daze
did that happen yeah it did because i
remember i walked up i think i went to
the wrong spot too like i didn't even
know what was going on and they were
like pointing this way oh i'm over here
okay
and going up there and i remember i
didn't prepare anything to say um
i was sitting alongside you know uh
james horner uh han zimmer
uh you know these guys who are just like
incredible and and and heroes in
different ways as well you know
especially james you know
uh who who sadly passed away but um
growing up listening to their stuff and
you're sitting in this row and you're
like all right this is just fun to be
here that's great and then you hear your
name you're like wait okay as you're
walking up there and i probably why i
didn't go the right way because i was
thinking you have to say something you
have to say what are you going to say
and all i can remember
was
that you know my parents were always
incredibly
supportive of whatever
ridiculous crazy thing we wanted to do
you know like they were they were both
teachers and they were both the kind of
people that like when i said well i want
to make movies and they're like uh i
don't know how to do that but my dad
would be like here's my movie camera and
i'll get you film
and we'll figure it out you know
so no matter what it was i wanted to do
growing up they were just always
encouraging uh which is which which i am
forever thankful for because the idea of
just being encouraged especially when
you're being encouraging about
creative things yeah most people are
like
get out there and play football or
baseball and that's that's it get a job
yes get it you know all this and
you know and if you mention art in any
fashion in many households in this
country it's like you can't make a
living doing art yeah you know it's
always like talking down to it and
always putting it in a position of
that's something you don't want to do do
this other thing which is more sensible
you know
uh my parents were the opposite of that
right they were just like this is so i
remember
i had friends who growing up whose
parents would tell them anytime they
wanted to do something creative or
artistic they would tell them it was a
waste of time it's a waste of time why
are you doing that to waste the time you
know you're just drawing yeah yeah it's
it's it's ridiculous it is absolutely um
but i remember just saying that um
just recounting that story you know
quickly
on stage and saying you know and if
you're a kid who's creative and you want
to do something do it you should do it
you know
it's it's not a waste of time i think
any kind of art is not a waste of time
no it's an expression of yourself and
you'll end up with an oscar yeah
yeah he's guaranteed guaranteed
that's the thing about art isn't it and
being creative even if
it leads to none of that
you are still i mean sitting in the
house and playing a piano picking up
isn't it great i'm doing a painting yes
what's going on right now
it's great yes that's what it's all
about it's just this being in touch with
yourself yeah yeah creatively and just
but putting that time into enjoying
something yeah in a very peaceful manner
yeah you know i love the fact that
you're saying that you you look at these
positive
things you're into positivity and all
that because so much of this ridiculous
world is the opposite of that yeah and
so much social media unfortunately
that's the reason why i jumped off
twitter i was on twitter for a while and
then i i started to connect to the fact
that it seemed like the dominating
narrative of twitter was one of a
slightly mean gossipy classroom yeah i
was like i don't want to be around
people
like just knocking other people's lives
or criticizing people
and then what i realized with instagram
if you want
instagram can just be a place where you
post a photo or post a video and you can
disarm comments and that's it you're
just saying hey here's something i saw
or something i liked and check it out
and then i started to realize that there
are there are a bunch of people trying
to change that nega
narrative on social media of like this
can be a place to come if you are
feeling down and maybe you want to see
fluffy dogs or funny kids or people
being silly yes um i did want to just
very quickly ask you because you were
talking about sitting next to
uh hans zimmer
if if someone out there listening to or
watching the podcast were to say were to
ask you
what would be
three amazing scores in movies that you
could go pick up that are a great kind
of learning experience for someone that
might want to do this for a living what
what are the standout ones for you i
would say
well i like the number three right
it's the rule of threes the comedy
comedy rule of
yeah i'll try and make it funny uh
well i would say number one
there's too many to list here so my head
explains but one of the ones i go to
right off the bat is uh lawrence of
arabia maurice jarri who who wrote that
score and if you watch that it's like a
a master class in scoring it's
incredible in thematics in
in tone in emotion all of those things
it's it's just such an incredible
uh piece of work i love it so much okay
last of arabia one okay number two i
would say would be um
planet of the apes the original one
you know to show you that it doesn't
always have to be traditional what
you're doing it can be something you
know emotion can be evoked by me
knocking on this table or or hitting
something against the wall or doing
crazy things in jerry goldsmith when he
wrote uh planet of the apes listen to
that score it is incredible and it is
nothing that you would expect you know
it's all weird yeah crazy stuff he would
he did what they call prepared piano
which is you put screws in between
strings you put pieces of wood in
between things so when you hit it it
suddenly sounds crazy and different
or you can just pluck the strings inside
the piano things like that and he had
all these crazy
ideas that he brought to that picture
which i thought were just incredible and
i remember as a kid hearing that and
just being like what is that what is
that sound you know i love that
um
so you'll have that and you've got a
nice cross section there because you've
got epic classic and then you've got
kind of experimental new wave and then
you've got one one left now michael i
know i know and i feel like i should do
something that is like you know
what's the third compliment to that
would be yeah but i'd be reaching
you should pick one of yours to be
honest
if i'd written one of them i'd pick it
yeah i would say but i would say uh
growing up listening this is not a
particular thing but but just growing up
listening to
disney movies it's like crazy disney
also had a huge importance you know put
a huge importance on all of their movies
you know from bambi guys like um
uh oliver wallace who wrote uh peter pan
that's one of my favorite scores ever
that original peter pan scored check
that out because that is just it's
beautiful um
also uh frank churchill did bambi i mean
all these guys that that that wrote
during that time they were incredible
musicians who were just trying to make a
living just trying to you know get by
but there's this incredible wealth of
music in the entertainment industry and
it's and you could spend years sifting
through all of it and it's all great
poltergeist oh spielberg right uh yeah
well yeah well toby hooper and then
eventually i think stephen took over
yeah uh i don't know exactly what the
story is behind that but yeah steven
spielberg produced for sure and uh but
jerry goldsmith did that score and
that's an incredible okay jerry
goldsmith's amazing like i love can i
remember that score yeah yeah it's i
don't hear
because i very often listen to it when
i'm falling asleep no one's asked you
and it gets it this is this gives you
amazing dreams like really amazing dream
if you're looking for amazing dreams
okay the soundtrack to the hours philip
glass oh philip glass is amazing very
cyclical
builds on its own kind of legend and
and kind of takes you in strange places
but it's this idea that because philip
glass is big on that right oh yes very
much melody and then yes builds on top
of it and it's a very meditative
kind of listening experience which i
love yes he was a taxi driver
philippines isn't that crazy and he's
like 80 some now you know i got to i got
to meet him and spend time with him it
was it was so incredible just to you
know he's such an incredibly nice
interesting person yeah he's she's great
billy and dom eat the world
well
should we eat the world do you want to
eat
johnny yeah our producer johnny clues
has actually over the last few months or
so been making his own three homemade
hot sauces and we've been saying to him
but not hinting to the audience john if
you get to a point where it's good to go
and ready to eat and tasty we've got to
have it on billion dollars so this is
the first of john's homemade delicacies
wow yeah this is the first well it has
it did make well immediately
uh
but this is john at the top of his game
creating apparently one of the greatest
sources known to mankind does he have a
name for it i don't know we'll ask him
when he comes in he's been he's he's i'm
toying with the idea of shooters sauce
oh yeah it depends on that's actually
pretty good isn't it yes i asked him the
other day and i said yes
i said how does it go in terms of spice
and it was like extra spicy
yeah i think it's spicy so sounds great
but we've obviously got a mild a medium
and a heart
oh here we go oh this is exciting veggie
tacos okay tacos you say john
have some chips okay
thank you
and he's going to tell us anything about
the uh oh yeah we'll do the veggie tacos
we'll do the chips right bills right
then
no no
there's plenty yeah come on oh really
all right i'll grab it i'll grab one of
them because i didn't skip lunch if i'm
honest we'll go mild medium hot so
there's johnny clifford yes the the rear
one will be the mild the real one this
one is an anaheim hot sauce
okay so michael
that thumb's been part of some amazing
cards over the years actually
that's really good right right off the
thumb it's great yes yes i'll put one on
a cracker there you go jump michael do
you know the soundtrack to the mission
yes that india morocco yeah that is the
greatest yeah i mean that's what i mean
it keeps going the well is too deep
viggo mortensen bought me that once did
they ever buy you anderson
he kissed you full on the mouth and
bought you gifts yeah he won't slap me
and kick me down a pair of stairs well
that's hey that's nothing that's
actually equal that's pretty good yeah
oh here we go johnny john i like spice
and i must save this is the mildest
there's a little bit of a kick there's a
nice kick to that
that's the mild it's now what's in that
one that's anaheim peppers uh i believe
i put like onion whole garlic
some
uh spices very spices maybe like parsley
dried spices and then just a salted
brine and then i fermented it for like
three and a half weeks i think really
hopefully that tame's the the spice
level john you need to calm down right
here
over there because you're getting very
excited are you having it on its own
yeah
now are you doing this just for yourself
are you going to sell these what's the
uh no it was a covid project i was just
bored i'm like i wonder how hard it is
to make hot sauce
it's not that hard the spoiler alert no
i think it's amazing that kovid was in
you know bad for lots of obvious reasons
but
good for digging into things that you've
either always wanted to do or something
you newly discovered that you wanted to
try and i feel like yeah there's going
to be books written about it
you know years to come did you do
something yeah what did you get into
this was new i did an album i did there
was a crazy album i wanted to do that i
never had a chance to do ever had time
to do and i was just i wanted to do this
you know you know in the 60s they would
have this there's this music exotica
music and it was basically like
what it would sound like to be somewhere
else maybe in the south pacific or
somewhere but it was very sort of um
thematic and it had lots of percussion
and all of this cool stuff and i used to
love that music we had a bunch of those
records when i was growing up and
loved it and i was like i want to make
one of those albums one day wicked so
and i also love um like radio theater i
love listening to you know old radio
shows and stuff like johnny dollar and
things like that the shadow um so i
thought maybe i could mix those two
ideas together so i did sort of this
science fiction story about someone who
visits earth and what that experience
was like and then each track was sort of
a different chapter in that story
yeah so i did that and put that out
through mondo what's it called it's
called uh
it's it's called uh oh jesus
so many jobs you do so many times i had
six movies this year i honestly i didn't
i didn't know that one was going to
stump you what is the name of your album
i honestly didn't think that was going
to be a difficult one
because i wanted to listen to it on the
way home
it was
they uh maybe the listeners can tell us
send us in
i bet john could find it where we go
let's do it right here right
yeah this is great this is embarrassing
let's get into the second source but we
have to score the first one oh no but we
score all three they're separate but we
can't do scores for all that will take
about three and a half but if we score
if we score i'm just all three that's
why i was like because it's it it
travelogue volume one traveling
volume
it's been a while i have to say william
i absolutely disagree that i like to do
it then let's just scroll the first one
right
flavor so michael we store we score
these things based on three different
categories flavor
the the aesthetic and usefulness which
was a billy uh category so aesthetic
meaning the color the look the okay the
vibe
so flavor
i'm gonna give mine a six out of ten
i'll give it a seven out of ten yeah
i'll give it a like i'll go seven out of
ten okay aesthetics is a nice colour i'm
gonna give it an eight out of ten yeah
it looks as though like blood has been
uh mixed with piss
i'm giving a uh
high score then kevin hannier said it
gets an eleven
that's a good one and then usefulness i
mean it's a hot sauce do you know what i
mean actually that'd be that'd be great
on scrambled eggs oh absolutely
yeah you can put it into all sorts of
cooking you can take it with you to a
cafe i'm giving it an eight and a half
out of ten then sure am i there right
this is the slightly hot one what do we
got here oh i'll give you a it's a
little it's so that will be the hardest
one
i'm gonna stop you johnny i'm gonna stop
it
needs to give her a score how useful it
is oh and how useful that's an eight for
me because yeah it's great i'll put it
on anything right this is the this is
the medium one that's the meme that's my
favorite
narrow
hot sauce i wouldn't say it's medium
it's probably like a medium it's like a
hot medium buffalo wild wings how did
you decide well that's what like
the hot scale do you actually oh well
because the raw habanero is like
obviously very hot because it's habanero
but the mango kind of tames it by you
know putting in like half a mango into
that but it's a little bit more fruity
which complements the habanero which
kind of has a fruitiness to it buffalo
wild wings which i should not be
advertising on the show but i'm going to
do it anyway they do
a whole slew of flavors with their wings
and they do a cauliflower wing if you're
a vegetarian and my favorite flavor that
they do is mango habanero john really
yeah it adds up here you go michael you
you kick that off all right
oh i'm exhausted
all right here we go right here we go
nobody panic
over here
it's a sneaker this one's different
it's a
here we go johnny
okay i'm sorry if i'm gonna have it just
on a on a chip
hmm
what oh oh i like it
are you all right it is magnificent well
that's amazing
that's medium i got the hot ones really
going to give us a talking too
i love hot sauce i can i love
any any level of it same i want to find
ghost peppers because that's like my
dream now now do you grow them any of
these yourself you can grow these
yourself have
really yeah i have a horrible gardener
but if dom maybe don should grow some
ghost peppers
yeah the uh
my girlfriend andrea she had this
incredible
garden through kovet she just went
garden crazy and she made this massive
garden uh of tomatoes and all kinds of
peppers and all kinds of i mean it was
incredible so in the morning i just go
grab a bunch chop them up throw them in
the eggs and it was
yeah now
she doesn't want to continue doing it
because it's so much worse
yeah it's a lot of work so it's it's you
know maybe something i tried growing a
few things all of them died
unfortunately
right now let's score it so flavor
aspect flavor aesthetics and usefulness
flavor i prefer that one to the mild one
i'm giving that john a nine out of ten
i'm enjoying it i'm giving it a name as
a good as a sword name as well michael
absolutely yeah wow wow
i prefer that look to the medium one
it's it's got a kind of a tangeriney
type version
yeah this one the one that's slightly
open yeah i'm gonna give it
i'm gonna give it an 8.5 for the for the
and it'll sneak up on you
because that that doesn't look hot no no
yeah i'm gonna give this look a ten
because when you when you when you
brought it when you brought it into the
room
i looked at that one i was like that's
the one i want to try because i don't
know it looks like it has a creaminess
to it yeah yeah it looks it's great will
it yeah i'll give it a 9.2 he's a high
choice
i mean that is the one i use mostly at
home oh it is you can obviously tell
because the anaheim one has nothing
missing so what listen what's the name
of this one again that one's just mango
habanero
but you add the mangoes after that
protein not adam during the fermentation
i would probably give the name
like a five yeah you need to work on the
name john so i think it needs something
more i mean maybe i'll name them after
your movies
the op source the inside out source
turned into haters
sorry about that guys if there's any
families listed
usefulness well it's the same as any
other hot sauce you put it in your
scrambled eggs you put it in your rice
dishes yeah i'm getting it
on anything even more because it's got
all my sandwiches i'm gonna go nine out
of ten this is guys right so now this is
the last one johnny yeah that one's
probably my second favorite it's going
to be a little bit hotter because
there's nothing to cut it with that do
you think you should be telling us which
is your first favorite i don't know i
feel like maybe
i don't know i feel like you're
oh now what's the name of this one john
that's just uh you know another really
unique name it's just called habanero
hot sauce so this is no mango no no
mango that's what you could call it no
mango michael no man
thank you
i'm just gonna try this simply on a chip
i mean it's hot but i don't it's not
hotter than the mango one
i did learn that like it's really good
it keeps fermenting when it's in those
bottles so it's like every
you know day it's essentially getting
milder and milder like really straight
up it probably would have been a lot
harder though what's the shelf life of
like
at what point it's like almost i'm not a
lifetime but it's a long time because of
fermentation it's almost like honey
where it just prevents it from
going rotten or anything i believe
i'd say
just maybe give your t-shirt a dusting
down because you're covered in crumbs
like an old man that's lost his mind
some of that's dandruff is it yeah some
hairs just the bigger little the bigger
pieces
it's bob's hair yeah some of that oh
pure
don't touch your eyes yeah no don't
touch your eyes
that's really good
john i enjoyed that yeah yeah that feels
like a very good like um everyday
hot sauce that one's that's why half of
it's missing i'm putting some more of
the mango one on my taco to finish off
yeah i built something as well
right should we give the final one some
scores yeah
well we should have did the the mango
one last we should have seen yeah
because it's
disappointed me now i'm sorry that third
source was yeah a distinct
disappointment yeah well there you go
you could call it distinct
disappointment source that's a good name
for it name again good name again
remember we were talking about sadness
i had a wave of sadness definitely
no it was actually really good
let's score it in that case billy you
kick it off start on the low end i know
it's still very good and if it was the
first source that it would have been a
high score it's the last song
right six out of
yeah it's not as good as the mango one
for me i'm gonna give it a seven point
five i was just gonna say seven point
five yeah there you go seven points
how does it look to you which one is it
again this one it's the one closest to
this one that one so all right it's well
yeah so it's it's a seven yeah seven in
terms of looks i'll give it an eight i
think it looks nice
yeah
is it useful i'll go i guess i'd go
seven and a half seven and a half is it
useful i mean is it any more useful than
the manga one i don't think so i think
the only use it has is to say that the
mango one is better yeah yeah yeah so
that's basically yes how useful it is
you put it against the mango one and you
say it's not as good it's the reason the
number two was invented exactly
okay yeah okay there we go okay i'll
give it for usefulness we'll give it a
four
i'll give it i'll be slightly more
charitable i'll give it a 5.5
oh wait on usefulness
i'll give it up i know six i mean you
know yeah i'll give it a six john a
success wow
yeah one of them these are great
give it a few minutes and you're going
to be like
yeah
and did you make the tacos too yeah no
those are from cactus tacos i'm vine
absolutely delicious tom well michael
it's been fantastic having you on as a
guest
we're all very aware of just how busy
and uh in in um
high demand you are you said you've got
five movies coming out this year six six
movies
i wouldn't actually name them because
you didn't even know your albums
believe me i've already tried this
before and i can't so let me try let me
try i'm going to say right jurassic
world yes
dominion and then uh spider-man yeah
for uh no way home um the batman
then thor love and thunder
and then uh there's another one uh a
movie called uh next goal wins which is
oh tiger's movie yeah yeah yeah yeah
great yeah it's a lovely movie i love it
so much sure in hawaii right yeah i know
from lost workers it's so beautiful cool
filming really so
tiger's the best and one of the greatest
people i loved i i was i got i was so
lucky working with i got to work with
him on jojo rabbit which was one of my
favorite but hunt for the wilder people
that he did that's one of my favorite
movies
i just love that movie so much so he's
so funny he's such a funny dude he's the
best um
look at the mess you've made
you're a disgrace well michael thank you
thank you for having me this was a blast
i couldn't believe it when we heard you
were coming off yeah we were so thrilled
michael oh come on no any time any time
i'm so lucky that i got to know you
during the um the making of loss because
if we'd have asked him at this point he
would have said absolutely that is not
true well because we got to i got to
know you what was that 15 years ago now
making lost 20 years ago maybe it's like
i think it was 72 years ago now
for the up theme yeah yes exactly yes
you and i first met in 1942 was it wow
yeah no that was that was an experience
it really was you know that was
a lot of people have said this to me
over the years and i totally agree with
it because of the way that tv watching
has changed now that we tend to binge
things that are on and something will
drop the whole season
last you could make a strong argument to
say was the last show that you had to
watch on that wednesday night because if
you missed it later on in the afternoon
someone would ruin the moment and you
couldn't wait to get to your group the
next day to talk about it right whoever
your group of friends were whether it
was at work or whatever it was right you
always wanted i felt like alias had a
bit of that too but lost was the king of
that yeah and it's what i love about
what marvel's doing in terms of their
shows the way that they'll put one a
week right you know you'll get one a
week so you get to i think you know with
my kids when they were growing up i
never let them binge things we always
had one a week you know because they
grew up watching like the brady bunch
and all these things we'd do one week
and i think in that week's time you get
to think about it yeah you know and you
get as opposed to when you're just
eating it like crazy like you know if
you were to get baked and eat uh 30 of
those whatever they called fizzy fizzy
sweets yeah fizzy sweets busy sweets
you're not enjoying them as much i agree
yeah i was saying to billy yeah so your
mind mugs are over and and if you watch
some of those really old weeklies
the end and the start would be kinda
different yeah because your mind would
go oh yeah that's okay yeah he wasn't
going to go over the cliff yes as much
as i thought he was yes yes no i i think
that's a huge thing should be put some
space between viewings it's important i
was saying to billy during covid
obviously there's been some crazy things
that have happened to all of us during
covet and and some hopefully positive
things that have happened as well the
thing that i am now trying to work at
getting back to where it was or
hopefully better is my attention span
yeah attention span took a real knock
jordan
no reading of books i was watching
little clips on youtube and like you
said michael i was binging whole seasons
yeah so now i just
tend to not lean towards shows that
don't allow me just to go i'm gonna
watch this for six hours and it's done
and it's fragged my attention span yeah
and it's very easy to do you know and
then especially during covet there's
also this crisis going on so you're
checking all the news and you're always
looking at this terrible stuff it's just
i think everyone's going through this
healing process of getting out of this
yeah what's happened and what is still
somewhat happening you know to us as
well we're just gonna have to live with
it well so happy to know michael that
during the covid experience which was a
topsy topsy turvy time for all of us you
were maintaining an amazing artistic
integrity yes i was writing an album
that i couldn't remember the title of
that i'm gonna listen to it in the way
home really it's been brilliant
thank you so much anytime hope to come
back yeah man yes thanks thank
you well dom that was
one of the more interesting interviews
that we've had with our good friend
michael cachino
um
i mean is there anything that you can't
do that man
musically i think that might be one of
the most impressive resumes and if you
want to see his resume online check it
out but the
movies that he's worked on in the last
kind of 20 years or so and we'll
continue to work on
what a lovely guy as well you know no
sort of ego about the whole thing now
he loves loves his job works from a
place of passion and obviously doing the
thing that he's always wanting to do so
of course you're going to be a happy
camper doing that um
fantastic thanks for tuning in guys of
course as we always mentioned if you
want to get in touch with us we love
hearing from you uh you can leave
comments on our youtube channel that's
the friendship onion at youtube you can
also leave
questions and concerns and rate and
review and subscribe wherever you listen
to our podcast and if you want to get
merchandise and look as cool as don does
this week with his friendship onion
t-shirt
you can get that at the
friendshiponionpodcast.com
yeah and we'll see you guys
next week see ya toodles
[Music]
harmonize with me and hold me tight all
through the night you're shining bright
i'm your oyster baby you're my pearl